first of all you guys are Comicon oh
geez so this is like this is old there's
nothing to you right
no are you used to it or does it cuz it
all haven't been here in years I think
the only time we were here was Winter
Soldier 2014 13 14 or something like
that I was like yeah they can't they
can't travel us that much it's like the
president in the vice president the CEO
and the CEO pit we got to be in two
separate places that have a car yeah
yeah so will you go over there at all
today and walk around a little bit maybe
ah doesn't know that was a solid maybe
of a solid no look at it and it words of
the great poet Lauryn Hill two MCS can't
occupy the same space at the same time
it's against the laws of physics okay
that's not me that's Lauryn Hill
Lauryn Hill have you guys dealt with the
fallout of endgame you know people were
not prepared I mean people were crying
in a theatre mm-hmm yeah the world's a
mess don't know it's all mess I mean
it's a mess in the movie how you dealt
with the end of anything it's been great
okay we went on a pretty nice vacation
yeah okay so far eighths I'm a punk
pistol what is that Yuriy number
nevermind I better juice Sebastian sorry
no system for the merge time cucumber
juice yeah always that you getting ready
for what if three five five view or
urine oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
happening right now
was this yeah I'm on oh I'm on a very
extreme die right now
it's very got to keep it don't you eat
no carbs no Kuni carbs no sugar you need
kind of film Oh are we gonna get a
Sebastian stand nude scene yes actually
whoa I knew it there cuts the people are
getting what they want
they're certainly trying there are some
amazing women in his movie right yeah
it's incredible
who is this we talked to me man it's
loopy that visits nigh that's what I'm
screaming hi
should come Lapita Penelope Cruz Jessica
Chastain Oh Diane Kruger and you to do
I'm the guy Edgar Ramirez is in as well
now but he you did too yeah I guess I
never get roles like this what are you
talking about really it's called it's
like do a part 2 of 3:10 to Yuma you on
3:55 you understand you're a 5 p.m.
there's a train that never comes back
ok that's the Train that's great man you
got some heavy hitters in there Jessica
Chastain yeah no it's pretty fun ellaby
crew yeah just I'm just observing and
taking it's also done just soaking it
all in
you do need a role where you can smile
more oh I don't know how spin-offs we're
here for Disney Plus for you guys right
can we talk about those a little bit kid
what can you tell us there's a angry guy
with one arm and there's a confused guy
with wings and they're in a show
together yeah we're just gonna try to do
our best
yeah survive what's the worst that could
happen a lot see there you go a lot you
know we lost Iron Man we have to make
sure we now it's just this this is what
you left with it's like you went in to
buy a Cadillac and came out with a Buick
and a Porsche
you know everybody wanted that Tesla but
you got a Prius you know what I mean we
are the Prius of the Marvel Universe at
it that's probably pretty accurate
there's some pretty good people coming
by the way for the Marvel red carpet not
Priuses
oh but the Tesla's all right if you test
those on it who is that come on you can
tell us can't you I don't know we're
gonna Angela we might get a get a piece
of this Angelina Jolie Oh in the in the
Marvel Universe oh you're so sweet
they better not kill off Bri Lawson and
is there a chance that you guys with me
in Black Widow will we see you and maybe
you pop up a black widow no think they'd
done shoot know I've know in the future
I'm pretty sure they'd done shoot done
all right one more Oh lot of it a lot of
people think that a lot of people is
just me me calling me look chances so
how to mirror this should be the Riddler
I did say that though I love that I used
to love that character when I was lucky
Sita dock casita yeah yeah our casita
oh no that Joker trailer looking pretty
good I gotta check it I haven't seen the
trailer I gotta check that you know
what's looking good the top guns really
did you see you saw him yo oh come on
man it's Tom Cruise on that little like
you know electronic piano kick this
don't um did you happen to see the cat's
trailer the cat's trailer yeah when you
put the music to it mmm yeah that's fair
you saw the cat you know in the hood
they called me I do it a ramen that's
what they call me
I'm an old-school cat said I saw cats
like 17 so you were you were off for a
part of that nah oh no what do you think
of the trailer though people scared of
black cats okay they say we bad luck I
don't know what don't cross my path you
know what happened today Tommy I don't
know
you know what did you see the trail I
did uh and your thoughts well I'm sure
it's just like when when you saw cats on
Broadway did you see cats on my can see
cats um so the first 40 seconds you're
like oh my god
they're like cats and then as soon as
the 46 second kick in you're like hmm
still cats it's great music great music
great music
let's go cats know they were on 50th and
Broadway forever yeah they were right
across from the it's coming back the
musical I think schools
Mamma Mia is there now Mamma Mia went in
for cats here I go